what's going on there citizens the reject Nation
we are going to watch today a clip from the Super
Mario Brothers movie I think this was released at
the game awards John how are you I am game tacular
how are you doing good thanks for joining me if
you guys need to catch my Jedi Survivor reaction
that is up here on the channel right now love
Fallen order so I was excited took that trailer
out alrighty let's see what's in store leave
a like leave the like button leave it a like
foreign
a little bit of that voice
yes I've been there buddy
get the sound design and the music it's great
okay so these bricks are just floating here
it's the only way to fly man go go
classic oh got it here we are Palace doors
Star platform
Mushroom Kingdom still barely hearing Chris
Pratt's voice I know trying to get a proper
assessment of how I feel about his voice such an
up and down experience but everything else was
Grand and beautiful that was like a no-brainer to
me I thought it looked it was just harkening back
to so much with the gameplay there's so many just
little little tiny background Easter eggs are out
but I was really appreciative of especially
the sound design invigorating that into your
film Toad's voice sounds excellent uh it's Keith
Michael Keel yeah they must have pitched him way
up yeah I mean it sounds to me it sounds just
absolutely excellent yeah and then the classic
tube pipe yes thank you yeah man great sound
design there it's a great blend I think really
because it brings the world to life in a way that
is more immersive like a full-on movie because you
know like the game sound designs are particular
in the facts of what they're accentuating for your
actual gameplay experience but yeah here to hear
it fleshed out with you know additional just you
know Street Sounds and then the music really fun
like and upset as people have been about Mario's
design himself like watching him move around I'm
like this feels like you made an open world Mario
game basically a lot of people are over it now
yeah I feel like maybe it's like the last hurdle
is the voice and even for me like you catch a
little bit of his voice when he's like oh what
is this this taupe thing you know and you know he
sounds like a New Jersey guy he sounds again still
sounds like Rocket Raccoon to me but even watching
this I was like ah Rocket Raccoon yeah he kind of
sounds like Rocket Raccoon to me you know Rockets
got that kind of you know he's got that thing you
know it's not great Rock but you know he's got
a similar accent at least in what I'm gleaning
here I'll take it over everybody thinking that
Chris press just gonna talk like Chris Pratt
yeah well I think the ex the way they've uh
animated the Expressions too feels human to
me yeah yeah yeah yeah the way Mario's designs are
like I really think they've brought that to life
in a great way like I enjoy the references of
like everything with like the Super Mario World
Super Mario 3D like the map looks great eight the
Mushroom Kingdom and all that and I think what I'm
enjoying about what we're getting with Mario thus
far is the fact that he seems like such a fish out
of water like you get so used to over the years
playing as Mario where some of these reactions
are a little bit more slight like when he is
jumping platforms and stuff sometimes they do
add in like oh you know like a tiny bit but here
he looks truly terrified a lot of the time and
really scared and even when he's going up the the
the tube he's like banging around and everything
like that and you get so used to over the years
playing confidently as Mario that I think they're
doing a really great job at putting him in place
as this character who really needs to learn some
skills and really needs to learn how to operate
around the Mushroom Kingdom and operate in this
landscape as he's the titular character going up
against such a big Baddie he has a big obstacle
to overcome it's not just going to be a walk in
the park for him I really like that quality and
you know as much as I'm still working my brain
around Chris Pratt voice because it's the only
voice that I hear I don't know if it's just
my mental Association of I'm aware it's Chris
Pratt so I put a little bit more emphasis on my
my critical subconscious ear on it you know or
like when I still have that even if I wasn't aware
is Chris Pratt doing it you know what I mean yeah
like is that interfering with it I will say though
that the few times where the camera was on him and
then he was speaking I think it matches well like
it doesn't sound at all to me like when I thought
Mario would sound like whatsoever I know you don't
want to do like uh bad it'll be annoying after a
while just sound like that right sound like a
noise the entire time but I still think like
the way it matches like the the the facial I mean
the mouth vocal movement with his lips and mouth
and all that you know what I mean sometimes
I look like a little bit awkward it matches
well with that at least yeah so my point with that
being is I imagine that it'll be it simple enough
experience to slip into when you're watching even
if you're like it's not the Mario voice I really
wanted but for the movie it works and I think
that's ultimately what's going to matter is like
but for the movie it works yeah absolutely because
I mean this is a Fresh coat of paint on everything
and and I think it's doing a nice job to show us
that like yeah this is very much uh spawned from
people who are you know in love and know Mario
well and I feel like certain things will change
and certain things will stay familiar and here
like part of me wonders what their motivation is
because I'm like they could quash all of this
internet mumbling if they just put out a full
scene of him talking but at the same time I feel
like they're also sort of teasing us and and using
the voice is almost this kind of carrot at the
end of a stick but I I get the impression as of
now that yeah once you watch a few minutes of just
you know consecutive movie with all that breathing
room it'll probably click into place you know it's
like hearing the 8-Bit things but in you know this
sort of lush polyphonic you know realization
especially in the scoring and stuff like that
and I don't know like I feel like at least again
the hints that they're giving us give me it hope
they're not making me angrier and I'm just taking
that as a sign yeah because I feel like it could
easily take things in that direction definitely
but yeah and I love what you said too about his
being a fish out of water because I think there
are a lot of times where you have a property like
this that is so big and prolific for a lot of
people where you think oh do we really need that
but I think here it's a really nice choice because
yeah on a movie scale and especially redefining
from the 90s movie I think it makes a lot of sense
to jump everybody in through this perspective and
then sure we can watch Mario go on to be like a
fully accomplished Adventurer and all that stuff
I don't know yeah like his attitude Mario's kind
of cute like nobody really talks about Mario that
way but like he's endearing here at least in the
animation and I kind of love that the animation
itself is able to lead that and you know is able
to endear me just based on you know spending a few
minutes in the world it doesn't feel like we're
just in another Despicable Me alrighty well let
me enjoy the clip yeah Super Mario Brothers
movie clip what'd you guys think of it did
you like it leave your thoughts down below be
sure to subscribe leave a like last one lessons
pandemic Jones PJ listen buddy I just wanted to
hop in here real quick and tell you I hope you
have a wonderful Christmas let us know what you
get for Christmas this year I hope you're able
to gift people with your presence that loving
presence of yours and for 2023 I just got a lot
of spirit at this time it stays in the video for
2023 I hope that you are able to make boatloads of
money and you're able to convert those boatloads
of money into increasing your pledge at patreon
because let's face it that's your real goal
in life to just contribute more to the real
rejects patreon page you're a good guy for doing
that and I respect the hell out of you buddy